who will be chancellor after the
elections
angela merkel has good chances of
keeping the job despite the nsa spying
scandal
in germany citizens don't elect the head
of government directly but they do have
opinions
i would be for ms mackel because i think
it's great that a woman is in power
yeah sometimes she's a bit slow to act
but she still knows what she wants
she's done a good job over the years
i wouldn't vote for mackel again it's
simply time for someone new
i was nice to know
the social democrats have placed their
bets on pair steinberg
he's not doing well in the polls right
now but he still hopes to win
i would vote for steinberg
i think he's more honest and has more
ambition
i wouldn't vote for either i don't agree
with either of them
if germans could vote for their
chancellor directly today 58 would favor
merkel only 27 would choose steinberg
but it is still two months till the
parliamentary elections and the race is
not yet over steinbeck is still
campaigning hard
the die will be cast on september 22nd